when I realized it was him that wasn't
until I was 40 and I went to rehab
because of your father yeah I thought I
was molested by this babysitter I said
the whole time you're thinking it's you
knew the molestation was going on but
you're thinking it's someone else my
girlfriend called my mom and said uh
Jason's you know good saying he was
molested by his father and she goes oh
my God I thought he forgot about that
forgot about
he goes
do you think he got molested and I go
yeah he goes you think it was me and I
go nah and he goes
right
that's it never spoke again of it never
like who do you think it was not one
question
this is your kid and I did not think
about that until later on in life where
I'm a dad
and now and now I'm like wait you would
not stop the conversation
oh this is [__]